so you got in trouble online you screwed
up you know what you did was wrong but
the question is how are you gonna make
things right
because I know that for most of you this
should seem very obvious how to
apologize how to publicly apologize but
honestly for the species known as the
youtuber it's proved quite difficult and
so I'm making this guide for youtubers
by a youtuber I've seen so many bad
apologies come to the pipe I just can't
take it anymore
I've made a severe and continuous I have
to put this out there I'm no apology
expert I have made mistakes in my past
and I've apologized most people received
it well and I think that's because most
communities they don't expect you to be
perfect and have the perfect words that
we're seeing an epidemic of bad public
apologies that just missed that all the
marks right there are a few things you
have to say and there's a few things
that you should not do and if you do it
right combine it you're gonna have it
probably a pretty good apology now
before we go further the first thing
first things first okay you don't do
this if you're not actually sorry I see
this happen way too much youtubers
apologize when they're not actually
sorry so step one of how to apologize as
a youtuber is don't apologize just
because you're dislike bar is over 50%
or what people don't like what you'd say
if you apologize every time people get
mad at you on the internet your
apologies are gonna mean nothing there's
so many youtubers they apologize like 10
times and then they wonder why people
don't take them seriously and not as
even get this one part right just be
authentic in your apology everything
else is pretty much covered that's
probably the biggest one that I see
people miss the mark on and I'm gonna be
showing you guys examples by the way as
we go through this to give you examples
what I mean to do right and examples of
what I mean to do wrong so we're gonna
go through this point by point we're
gonna go through the positives first how
do you give a good apology and then
we're gonna go through like the
negatives what makes a bad apology
obviously the first one already said it
authenticity just that goes without
saying
step two you have to actually say you're
sorry for what you did not sorry for how
people feel people say hey I'm sorry if
I offended anyone hey nobody cares about
that that's not really sorry I'm sorry
if your feelings got hurt that's not you
being sorry that's you being sorry that
you're now
in trouble like I'm sorry you
misinterpreted me is not an apology
however I do feel like I owe you guys an
apology I am sorry to each and every one
of you who vote like that was not made
clear enough to you so if that's the
case if that's how you feel
don't apologize just say here's what I
meant step 3 and this is a pro tip okay
pro tip right here give a shared
commitment to the violated moral values
okay that's a mouthful here's what I
mean like PewDiePie is a great example
of he actually did a really good apology
when he had his whole controversy right
when he did his video he the first thing
he says you probably won't believe me
when I say this but whenever I go online
and I hear other players use the same
kind of language that I did I always
find it extremely immature and stupid
and I hate how I now personally fed into
that part of gaming what is that saying
to you it's saying a it's addressing
your skepticism you probably won't
believe me when I say this but number
two is it says hey I'm also offended by
that language I always find it extremely
immature and stupid I may have had a
heat him up but I'm also offended by the
language that shared commitment to like
moral values is a really big thing you
have to let people know hey I also don't
like when people do what I did which is
why I don't agree with what I did step 4
actually show remorse and regret for
what you did and not like a halfway
thing what people do a lot is they try
to explain away what they did and they
don't actually seem sorry that's just
about like taking accountability you
have to accept the fact that you did the
thing you caused the problem and
regardless of what happens regardless of
whether you think so and so caused you
to do this or whatever like you need to
actually just take blame right and here
once again I'm gonna have to use the
pewdiepie example where he talks about
there are no excuses and I'm not gonna
make any excuses to why it did because
there are no excuses for it I messed up
I'm disappointed in myself people like
to see that people like to see that you
know that
your fault you're not gonna push the
blame on somebody else you caused the
problem and you're apologizing for it
heads like a super big deal number five
is a big one it's that you actually have
to change and like make amends where you
can you can even salvage a really bad
apology by executing this well by really
showing you've changed a good example is
a people this might give me some hate
but Logan Paul he made he made a joke
about it like that he's reformed just so
you know I am an ex controversial
youtuber that's yeah it's no longer me
but actually a lot of people you see in
his whole community has turned around
from being like this toxic hate fest to
something a lot more positive and it's
because he's actually not only said he's
sorry which it was a terrible apology
but then by making actual steps to
becoming better now all of a sudden his
community is positive people are more
positive towards him it seems like he's
gotten over his controversy all because
he executed on that well so I'd say
that's like it's the most underrated
thing is to really show that you've
changed and that's just a long game
thing step 6
the reason you're apologizing oftentimes
the common refrain is he's only
apologizing because he got caught you
don't want people to think that when
you're apologizing so it's good to show
that you have real reasons for
apologizing and maybe address the fact
that hey you guys are probably gonna be
skeptical of why I'm apologizing but
it's actually because I'm sincere a
great example of this is Linus tech tips
did an apology to Tim Sweeney and he
addresses in the video hey it's actually
probably a better idea for me not to
address it at all the easiest thing for
me to do at this point would be to
roughly add up how many people are mad
at me for slinging a false accusation
based on my own arrogance and ignorance
conclude that it's probably not worth
the PR damage of drawing any further
attention to this and
move on but I feel bad and I'm going to
address it anyways even though I know
it's probably worse for my career to
address it mr. Sweeney
I have no idea if you'll watch this but
the only action left for me right now is
to issue my apology in full view of the
million or millions of people who watch
this video and show you that even though
I was careless and disrespectful I do
still know how to do my homework and
correct misconceptions about technology
even if in this case I was the one who
spread them that's a really powerful
move because it's saying to the audience
hey I'm not doing it because it's
convenient I'm doing it because I
actually I'm sorry finally step 7 Oh for
the love of everything please make it
short and sweet guys
the 20 minute apology I don't know maybe
it's just me it doesn't work yes I'll
just say hey actually I don't know I'm
not like I said I'm not an expert but
I'm just gonna give my personal take
here and maybe you guys feel similarly
but I don't know dude
a lot of times people don't care about
the drama they don't want to know the
ins and the outs of the situation if you
messed up you messed up just say sorry
get it over with be done with it but
this like these like 20 minute rants
number one the reason they're 20 minutes
is usually because you're trying to
explain away why you did what you did
but number two nobody gets to the end of
it so no one actually hears the full
thing alright but that's basically it
right pretty simple and now let's talk
about how people mess up because there
are a lot of things that can just poison
your apology such that even if you're
sincere about what you're saying
it just makes people think you're not
sincere even when you are so don't do
any of this number one the cliches you
exist in a bigger ecosystem than
yourself and when you apologize people
are gonna judge it next to other
people's apologies and if you apologize
in a way that other people have
disingenuously apologized it's gonna
make you come off disingenuous so when
you do the big or you like put film
yourself turning on the camera or
whatever even if you don't mean that to
be like manipulative people think it's
manipulative so it will come off that
way number two don't be overdramatic
please the perfect example this girl
right here who literally read for
apology as PO
tree with sad music in the background my
cards are all out on the table now will
you look or will you fold what the hell
is this right what am I supposed to
expect it's it's too performative it
doesn't come off as sincere and it goes
back to the authentic thing things that
are overdramatic and like you know
you're making almost too many gestures
like you're like pleading with the
audience - oh please apologies forgive
me it's gonna come off disingenuous
people are gonna believe you don't do
that all right and that brings me right
into another point no more of these
doughy eyes maybe again this maybe comes
to a purse like an opinion thing I want
to differentiate between what I actually
think are objective things you can do
wrong and right and maybe opinion things
I don't know if this is like objectively
bad or just it's my opinion but these
doughy eyes that people do like logan
paul this is one of the things that made
his video so painful to watch because
you've got these eyes that like super
wide like I'm so sorry like please
forgive me it's this pleading face that
makes it makes you look desperate
and makes you look desperate to be
forgiven rather than just apologetic for
what you did
the finebros did this they just have
these weird like weird look in their
eyes like they're pleading you please
understand it just doesn't come off well
whether you're sincere or not the doughy
eyes thing is not it's not a good look
the best thing to do is just give a
neutral statement just you have your
statement you read your statement you
try to be yourself and that's it there's
another pitfall which is you can try to
be too authentic which is what I see
sometimes where people try to turn on
the camera also like having not even
present gotten themselves with good
lighting or presenta bility and this
also looks bad and at this point you
might be thinking oh there's actually
more ways to mess this up than I thought
and yes that's actually true there's a
lot of ways to mess up an apology like
for example when James Charles makes his
first response video right and he's all
crying and you can tell he hasn't slept
like that's just not a good look
regardless of what he says he also made
it did a terrible job of explaining
himself but that's just a bad look you
have to be minimally presentable this
doesn't mean that you get fully glammed
up
but you have to minimally get some sleep
like sky Williams I don't know if you
guys are following the smash drama he
did a livestream just the guy looks like
he hasn't slept he's looking like he's
at the edge of a nervous breakdown
that's not the time to apologize it
doesn't come off sincere it just comes
off like you're scared you're scared of
your career being taken away and that
gives the impression you're just
apologizing cuz you're caught so just
clean yourself up it doesn't mean you
can't be authentic but at least you know
get some rest
eat your Wheaties in the morning get
yourself a full breakfast please guys I
can't take any more of these impromptu
turn on my webcam things it's 10:00 it's
tearing us apart okay it makes you look
panicked it makes you look like you're
just afraid you're getting caught if I
can give any advice and obviously again
I'm not really someone to give advice I
don't really know what I'm doing either
I just know what doesn't work but like
when you mess up it feels it always
feels like you need to respond right
away but just the people who are in it
for the drama want you to respond right
away you can take time to like collect
yourself step back from the situation
decide hey am i sorry
yes apologize and a think about actually
what you're going to say before you say
it say it or no I'm not sorry's I'm not
gonna apologize but don't do this thing
where like you just run straight to the
webcam it's just like never works moving
on we've got a personal pet peeve of
mine it just comes off so bad and that's
excusing yourself or shifting blame I'm
looking at the beauty community for this
because they're always throwing shade of
each other but I'm gonna use toddies
apology as a specific example this lady
this 30-plus year old got on a 40 minute
apology to basically not apologize and
just shift blame onto a bunch of other
people for why she committed a bunch of
wrongs James I am so sorry that I
allowed myself to be poisoned and
weaponized against you I'm sorry that I
bought in to any of their lies believing
those lies and allowing myself to be
gas-lit into making that video is one of
the biggest regrets of my life that's
not an apology and no one will ever
forgive you for that because you're not
actually apologizing so there's nothing
to forgive you for it's just you're just
trying to make it seem like you didn't
do what you did so that's
100% of the time a bad luck stop it a
couple more things that were done and I
know this list is really long but they
youtubers keep making these mistakes
stop self victimizing okay when you're
sorry
the goal isn't to make people feel bad
for you I see this all the time I
literally hate to bring her up again but
it's like the most recent relevant
terrible apology is toddy Westbrook from
the beauty community her whole apology
was just blaming other people and making
herself seem like the victim like she
was ghastly right that was the word of
the day I was just lit by Shane Dawson
and Geoffrey Geoffrey start believing
those lies and allowing myself to be
gas-lit I was beyond gas lit it's not my
fault that I made this video it's their
fault they gasps let me whatever and so
the apology just turned into feel bad
for me because I'm not actually the bad
person you're after trash straight trash
finally last but not least this is just
like kind of an overarching thing what
really makes an unsuccessful public
apology is that you don't seem like
you're actually sorry you seem like
you're just apologizing to get away from
the drama and to get away from like the
controversy and that that's something
hard because it's like it's just a
feeling you get so there's nothing you
can really do it's a combination of like
you being authentic just in general and
your audience trusting you to be honest
it's also a combination of like how you
present yourself if you're reading off a
script the whole time like toddy
Westbrook dead that's gonna look bad
it's just this because you're just like
this the whole time it doesn't come off
as very authentic it comes off very
prepared once again like you don't
actually mean it so that's like the last
thing to take into consideration that's
basically it that's how you give a
apology as a youtuber ultimately just
take accountability and you know just be
like hey screwed up it's my fault I'll
be better and then actually be better so
yeah that's it that's all I wanted to
share with you guys today this is for
all you youtubers out there who are
wondering how do I do it
how do I not screw it up that's the
guide I'll put a little shorthand list
in the kind of the description below you
go check that out
references
and that's all for now thanks for
watching see ya